are you uh are you comfortable there um  is the light in here too bright i'm cool  man i'm good cool cool cool nice you  want drink are you thirsty no ac good do  you like the temperature i'm good is  there carpet bothering you do you want  socks do you like reading i'm not gonna  read a book with it's too bright in here  right like i should turn the lights on  i'm comfortable i'm good have you read  dune uh maybe another time anyways suit  i don't know how to tell you any other  way that i don't really need that in my  life i get it  do you want to go for a walk no do you  like hikes no do you not a lot of civil  war facts no did you vote um do you want  to watch a movie yeah yeah i'll watch it  no okay yeah nice okay sick  okay yeah well we'll watch a movie  actually i don't  i don't really want to watch a movie  though  nope  well do you like listening to things